[Música]
Montevideo podría quedarse sin agua
potable Dentro de poco tiempo Uruguay ha
padecido la peor sequía en 74 años y la
consecuencia es una crisis
hídrica sin precedentes por ejemplo en
el embalse de canelón grande que es una
importante Fuente de Agua para la
sedienta capital los niveles han sido
tan bajos durante tanto tiempo que ahora
el césped cubre gran parte de lo que
solía ser un lago esto ha llevado a los
frustrados residentes a depender del
agua embotellada y gran parte del
recurso hídrico que sale a través de sus
grifos ahora presenta más sal y más
cloro de lo usual el pasado 19 de junio
el gobierno de Luis lacalle Pou declaró
estado de emergencia en Montevideo y sus
lugares aledaños Pero todavía permanece
la pregunta se podría quedar Montevideo
y específicamente el área metropolitana
sin agua potable Cuáles son las medidas
de urgencia que está tomando el gobierno
uruguayo para mitigar la crisis y qué
papel tiene la emergencia climática en
este caso de Uruguay para debatir estos
temas hoy en el debate conectamos con
Carol Arriaga ella es ex senadora y
coordinadora del programa atención
primaria ambiental del Ministerio de
ambiente de Uruguay y con Raúl viñas
magíster en meteorología y profesor de
agroclimatología en la facultad de
ciencias agrarias integrante también de
movus que es el movimiento por un
Uruguay sustentable gracias a ustedes
dos por acompañarnos y a nuestros
usuarios Los invito a que dejen todos
sus comentarios en las redes sociales
con el hashtag el debate f24 estamos en
Twitter streets Facebook e Instagram
como arroba franz24 raya al piso es y a
mí me encuentran como arroba
maríaclaguirre también quiero saludar a
quienes nos escuchan a través de las
plataformas de Apple podcast Spotify
deezer y TuneIn
Carol bienvenida aquí al debate de
France 24 Comencemos con la pregunta que
3,5 millones de personas están haciendo
en Uruguay se va a quedar Montevideo sin
agua
Bueno muy buenas noches un gusto estar
con ustedes y tratando este tema que
para nosotros es tan importante
El el en Uruguay crecimos pensando que
podíamos tener cualquier tipo de
problemas menos de agua
Lamentablemente eso no es así y ha
tenido que que pasar esta crisis para
que todos los uruguayos tomemos un poco
más de conciencia de lo importante de
cuidar el recurso agua
yo creo que
vamos a salir de esta crisis va a pasar
Hace unos días logramos que en la Cuenca
logramos no en la Cuenca de Santa Lucía
llovió que es gran parte de la zona
donde ustedes mostraban en el mapa donde
yo vivo es donde nace el río Santa Lucía
que es la fuente de de más importante de
agua dulce para potabilizar que tiene el
país y bueno y logra logró que subieran
un poco los niveles de del agua dulce
para potabilizar en el país se están
llevando adelante distintas acciones
para asegurar que en toda la zona
metropolitana haya acceso al agua que en
este caso
no es no tiene los estándares de
potabilización que que debería pero que
ayuda a lo que es que siga siendo activo
el saneamiento la parte de de del agua
del uso no Para tomar pero sí para los
distintos usos este que se dan en la
casa no y que nuestros pobladores tengan
acceso a esa agua que si bien Hoy no es
con no está con los estándar de
potabilidad que debería tener si en esta
emergencia hídrica en una emergencia se
puede beber no se aconseja para
distintos este vecinos que sufren
distintas patologías pero es un agua que
que se asegura que la zona metropolitana
siga teniendo el acceso al agua y ya
vamos a analizar en profundidad las
causas de este problema y las
consecuencias que ha tenido y también
estos niveles de potabilidad de los que
usted habla Pero antes quiero darle la
bienvenida también a Raúl viñas Gracias
por acompañarnos y pasarle También la
misma pregunta que le hicimos a Carol se
quedará Montevideo y el área
metropolitana sin agua
Bueno buenas noches
un saludo también para Carol este
realmente la pregunta para contestarla
directamente el gobierno dice que no el
gobierno dice que no va a quedar la
ciudad el área metropolitana sin agua
nosotros Esperamos que eso se cumpla el
tema es que la calidad del agua que
estamos teniendo evidentemente no es la
calidad como también decía recién Carol
de ser agua potable o sea el agua que
hoy recibe la ciudadanía por sus
servicios de la osce la empresa del
estado que se encarga de la distribución
de agua potabilización y distribución de
agua no cumple los estándares de agua
potable que es el cometido de esa
empresa lo cual nos colocan primera
instancia en un problema de cierta forma
legal de cómo hace la empresa para
cobrar un servicio que no es el que ella
está brindando los decretos tarifarios y
demás marcan que el servicio de la
empresa del estado de la osce tiene que
ser de agua notable no tiene no está
capacitada no está autorizada la empresa
a brindar ningún otro servicio y hoy
está brindando un servicio en cierta
manera deficiente se entiende por
supuesto que esto es a condición de lo
que vemos en las imágenes desde hace
tres años el país se enfrenta a una
sequía con algunos pequeños intervalos
en los cuales mejoraron algo la cosa
desde octubre del año pasado las
reservas que abastecen a Montevideo
canelón grande y la reserva Severino
algo más de 80 millones de metros
cúbicos han desaparecido o sea se han
utilizado Y actualmente se mezcla desde
hace ya más de un mes con una
autorización temporaria por 45 días que
dio el Ministerio de salud pública se
mezcla el agua del río Santa Lucía con
el agua que ingresa desde el río de la
plata un río que normalmente es bastante
salobre porque tiene una gran
comunicación con el océano y que ingresa
por el curso de Santa Lucía hasta las
represas que estamos viendo o sea al no
haber agua del río río abajo el río de
la plata ingresa agua el agua que
tenemos hoy plantea algunos
inconvenientes los niveles de cloruros
los niveles de sodio sean 100 los
niveles de cloruro de sodio son
complicados o sea son más del doble de
lo que se permite para que el agua sea
potable y el hecho de tener que utilizar
fuertes tratamientos químicos para
lograr la inocuidad desde el punto de
vista bacteriológico ha generado la
presencia en el agua de otras sustancias
que no son para nada aconsejables
Lamentablemente nuestro sistema político
se ha dedicado a echarse la culpa uno al
otro Este nosotros yo formo parte del
movimiento por un lugar sustentable y
desde a él lo que estamos viendo Es que
es necesario dejar de echarse la culpa y
empezar a hacer propuestas hacer llover
es muy difícil yo soy meteorólogo
también sabemos que dependemos de la
lluvia que nos pueda llegar las
condiciones atmosféricas no son las
adecuadas
tenido suficiente humedad en la
atmósfera como para generar las lluvias
que necesitamos la pocas lluvias que se
dieron en la semana pasada son apenas
paliativo como poner una curita en una
herida grande y estamos esperando
algunas lluvias Entre hoy y mañana pero
que también no llegarían a recuperar la
humedad que faltan los suelos después de
como yo decía recién tres años de seca
en los cuales si sumamos la lluvia de
tres años apenas llegamos a lo que
hubiera sido casi normal en dos o sea lo
quiero interrumpir lo quiero interrumpir
porque ustedes bien nos explicaba que
del río Santa Lucía ya no está
proponiendo la gran cantidad de agua que
se consume en Montevideo y el área
metropolitana sino que ahora están
dependiendo en gran medida del río de la
plata Que como usted lo dice tiene unos
niveles de sal mucho más altos y al
respecto el Ministerio de salud pública
habla de un agua que si bien no es
potable si es bebible pero tal como lo
dijo Carol desde el Ministerio de salud
pública se han emitido algunas alertas
de que por ejemplo las personas con
problemas de riñones o con problemas
cardíacos es mejor que no consumen esa
agua sino que la compren embotellada se
ha visto alguna consecuencia por la
cantidad y el aumento de la sal y el
cloruro y y perdón y el cloro
en la salud pública hoy la ministra de
salud pública informó que no se habían
detectado consecuencias importantes en
ese tema lo que sí se ha visto son
importantes consecuencias en la
industria la utilización de agua salobre
no es adecuada para muchas industrias la
la destilería de petróleo la refinería
de petróleo ha tenido que desalinizar
agua para poder seguir con sus procesos
muchas otras industrias se han
encontrado con problemas y también al
desde el punto de vista de la gente se
ha encontrado problemas por ejemplo en
los calentadores eléctricos de agua y
otros aparatos que no se llevan bien con
la sal y que evidentemente generan un
perjuicio incluso económico a muchas
familias Más allá de que por otra parte
la idea de tener que comprar agua es una
idea muy de Mercado una idea que es lo
que se ha tomado como solución pero y el
estado está proveyendo de agua a las
personas que tienen menos capacidad
económica pero evidentemente es un golpe
económico para todos porque nosotros en
el Uruguay estamos acostumbrados a que
nuestra agua sea bebible y potable o sea
sea agua sana y agua de calidad que uno
pueda servirse con confianza desde el
sistema público que provisiona el agua
todo a todo el mundo de aquí a toda la
población este un sistema que además se
basa en que cada uno tenga el agua en su
casa o sea no existe el agua comunitaria
Pero quizás habría que tomar otras
medidas yo te decía desde el nosotros
trabajamos mucho con medidas hacia
adelante y una de las cosas que es
absolutamente inaceptable que se viene
dando desde hace muchos años
lamentablemente es el hecho de que la
red de agua potable del área
metropolitana pierde la mitad del agua
que quita que saca del río y que
potabiliza generando en primer lugar una
necesidad de agua mucho mayor que la que
corresponde al consumo de la población
en segundo lugar encareciendo el
servicio porque hay que contabilizar dos
litros por cada litro que llega a la
gente y En tercer lugar aumentando la
necesidad de productos químicos para esa
potabilización
arreglamos eso cualquier otra cosa que
hagamos no va a servir porque Seguiremos
perdiendo el agua a propósito de ese
punto que usted nos señala Le quiero
preguntar a Carol sobre Cuáles son las
causas estructurales de esta falta de
agua potable en Uruguay específicamente
en Montevideo Porque si bien hay un
impacto sin duda y un factor ambiental
que es la sequía que ya lleva más de
tres años
Cuál es también las causas humanas o de
lo que se ha hecho o no se ha hecho en
Uruguay como lo decía Raúl la pérdida de
parte del agua potable en en la red
pública
desde la década del 70
es más o menos
se hicieron estudios acá en Uruguay y se
proyectó en en las grandes líneas que se
tenían que que seguir para tener
seguridad con el abastecimiento del agua
en cantidad y en calidad la década del
70 en Uruguay se ha ido invirtiendo
en en a través de de los distintos
gobiernos pero esas esas inversiones han
sido insuficientes de acuerdo al
crecimiento
demográfico que también ha tenido
nuestra capital en verdad el problema
hídrico importante la tiene la zona
metropolitana este no todo el Uruguay y
con respecto a eso yo creo que que hay
que seguir ahondando en
a ver como te decía al principio
nosotros teníamos la visión en Uruguay
de que el agua no era un problema de que
teníamos calidad y cantidad y que
podíamos tener otros problemas de
desarrollo pero no que tuvieran que ver
con el acceso al agua y menos al agua
potable esta esta crisis que tiene que
ver más con creo yo con el cambio
climático que muchas veces hay personas
que lo lo minimizan pero
cuando vemos estas situaciones
claramente tiene que ver con el cambio
climático también que que nos repercute
en en este caso en el acceso al agua no
en la falta de lluvias
nosotros tenemos que tener ahora la
capacidad de De darnos cuenta que hay
que hacer una mayor inversión en lo que
tiene que ver en en obras para asegurar
el acceso al agua potable a nuestra
población nosotros tenemos hoy una sola
forma de abastecer el agua potable a la
zona metropolitana que es a través de
aguas corrientes una planta
potabilizadora que se abastece con el
agua de la Cuenca del río Santa Lucía
especialmente específicamente el
gobierno nuestro gobierno apenas comenzó
en el 2020 cuando quiso avanzar que ya
tenía su planificación asegurar el el
acceso al agua potable en la gran
capital se vino la pandemia entonces
Obviamente que hubieron dos años muy
difíciles donde todos los esfuerzos se
enfocaron a lo que era la realidad que
estábamos viviendo que que eran todo el
mundo porque en Uruguay también este era
algo muy particular
salimos de esa pandemia y obviamente
seguimos enfocados en esto pero la
sequía ya venía Sí y la faltas de de
obras en tiempo y forma para prevenir la
sequía que ya estaba
Lamentablemente ese que hablen expuestas
no desde el 2013 por lo menos el
entonces ministro
de ministro de defensa huidobro ya había
advertido se habían hecho grandes
estudios en Uruguay nuevamente y había
advertido la fragilidad de del acceso al
agua potable que tenía todo el sistema
Metropolitano y y en verdad no se
invirtió como se tenía que invertir en
el después en el segundo gobierno 2015
ahí se comenzaron a hacer acciones para
represar más agua y darle más seguridad
A lo que es La Represa de aguas
corrientes que lleva agua potable a
Montevideo Lamentablemente se avanzó muy
lento y no se llegó lo que sí creo que
tenemos que hacer ahora es
unirnos dejarnos de mirar para atrás y
mirar todos juntos para adelante
entender que todos estamos Unidos que la
capital del país también
es parte del resto del país porque el
agua que llega a nuestras que se genera
nuestra sierras es la que abastece de
agua la capital del país Entonces
tenemos que entender que si hay una
sequía en el campo también afecta la
gran capital y tenemos que trabajar
juntos para que estas obras que se
necesitan se lleven adelante y que
nuestro en el futuro esto ya no sea un
problema para el Uruguay agua tenemos lo
que sí tenemos es que invertir más
Y como decía Raúl invertir más
obviamente en todo la la
cañería y todo lo que se necesita
para que haya las mínimas fugas posibles
en el agua que se potabiliza
yo estuve en el 2000 la voy a
interrumpir y les voy a pedir a ambos
que puedan ser más concisos para poder
aprovechar mejor el tiempo y ahora nos
cuenta su experiencia personal pero
quiero trasladarle la misma pregunta a
Raúl porque Carol apunta al crecimiento
demográfico a la crisis climática y
también a la falta de una acción
oportuna y es que ahora ante toda esta
crisis hídrica el gobierno está haciendo
unas obras contra reloj para intentar
llevar más agua a esta planta de aguas
corrientes de la que nos hablaba Carol y
la idea es ahora nutrirlo también con el
río San José pero lo hace ahora después
de tres meses en los que comenzó esta
crisis hídrica Ya a punto de quedarse
sin agua la capital y el área
metropolitana Raúl actúa tarde del
gobierno
Bueno realmente sí no tenemos más que
decirlo O sea no hay forma de decirlo de
otra manera
sin ánimo de atacar directamente lo que
sí tenemos que decir es que tenemos
muchos años de inactividad en el tema
obras que se tenían que haber hecho si
sustituyeron por otras y Lamentablemente
como yo decía en la intervención
anterior el sistema político no ha
estado a la altura del problema en toda
sustentación ha habido Reproches de uno
al otro rápidos muy fuertes pero lo que
nos falta hoy es y comparto ahí con caro
tenemos que estar Unidos y tenemos que
armar un plan lógico la primera parte
del plan tiene que ser reparar esa red
que pierde la mitad del agua que levanta
porque nadie que tenga una pérdida de
agua en su casa decide agregar agua al
sistema solamente sin arreglar la
pérdida porque no es así como trabaja la
lógica después tenemos que reconociendo
también como dice caro el que existe
mucha agua dulce en el país tenemos que
buscar de aguas dulces que están dentro
del país quizás no tan cerca como está
el río Santa Lucía desde Montevideo la
distancia de la potabilizadora que se
estableció allá por 1871 es unos 50 55
kilómetros de distancia quizás tengamos
que buscar un poco más lejos y tenemos
que además en la Cuenca de Santa Lucía
no solamente aumentar la capacidad de
represar o sea desarrollar los embalses
que desde hace 50 años se prevé que se
tenían que hacer a medida que la
población iba creciendo y del cual el
último se inauguró en
1986 Y a partir de ahí no se hicieron
más estaban previsto dos más pero no
solamente hacer los envases sino que
cuidar en sí la Cuenca Porque de nada
sirve tener agua embalsada si esa agua
se llena hacia no bacterias si esa agua
tiene graves problemas encarece y hace
muy difícil la potabilización y en la
potabilización el agua adquiere
características que no la hacen sana con
lo cual terminaríamos potabilizando agua
para terminar con un agua de cualquier
manera de baja calidad cuidar la Cuenca
es uno de los puntos entonces también Y
a partir de ahí
arreglando las redes
consiguiendo el agua quizás de otros
puntos de agua dulce de nuestro país
como puede ser el río negro a 250
kilómetros de distancia que tiene un
embalse que es más de cien veces los
embalses que tenemos en la Cuenca de
Santa Lucía porque es un río mucho más
caudaloso buscando quizás agua Incluso
en el río Uruguay un río que por sí solo
algunos análisis dicen que podría
abastecer de agua potable para beber a
todos los seres humanos del planeta para
dar una idea del tamaño que tiene ese
río ahí también tenemos que buscarla
pero sobre todo tenemos que buscar que
los recursos económicos que tenemos que
no son nunca abundantes los recursos por
definición no son abundantes sean
suficientes y adecuadamente usados para
suplir este problema para solucionar
este problema a fin de que en el futuro
no volvamos a encontrarnos con
situaciones como estas que son muy
complicadas yo veo la gente cargando los
bidones en la calle veo la gente
llevándolos a su casa
con un costo importante Más allá de que
se hicieron reducciones de impuestos que
hay que reconocerlas es un costo que la
gente no está acostumbrada a tener en su
presupuesto nuestro país no está
preparado para este tipo de cosas hay
que prepararlo y hay que prepararlo bien
y lo primero es solucionar la red y
después Buscar nuevas Fuentes en esa
búsqueda de nuevas Fuentes usted
menciona el río Uruguay y hay otra
fuente que no sé y Carol es la pregunta
que le quiero hacer si puede surtir a la
capital y es el acuífero guaraní que es
una de las fuentes de agua subterránea
más grande de todo el mundo pero que se
ubica en el norte del país y actualmente
no nutre al área metropolitana es
posible tomar agua de ahí
la verdad que el acuífero guaraní es una
reserva de agua la segunda reserva de
Agua Dulce a nivel mundial que tiene que
que tenemos
eso No no tengo los el conocimiento ni
los estudios necesarios como para saber
si Sería posible lo que sí nuestro país
nuestro gobierno está llevando adelante
un proyecto que para mí es muy viable
que también está el marcado en esas
líneas de trabajo que se plantearon en
la década del 70 de de la
infraestructura que teníamos que tener
para asegurarnos del agua potable que es
el proyecto arasati que si bien ha
tenido y tiene este algunas objeciones
por parte de de de diversos grupos creo
que es el proyecto más viable y que
además está llevando adelante este
gobierno desde el vamos para asegurar
que el que si hay un evento Como por
ejemplo este sequía u otro evento que
que
hace que la la principal vía de de
acceso a agua para potabilizar este no
no funcione e igualmente Montevideo
tenga y la zona metropolitana tenga
asegurada el acceso el acceso al agua
potable Ese es el proyecto arasati que
en estos días Ayer específicamente si no
si mal no recuerdo este se abrían los
los pliegos de la licitación y este y es
un proyecto que es la llave de seguridad
para el mantenimiento del agua potable
en la gran ciudad en la zona
metropolitana
ese proyecto este gobierno se decidió
desde el primer momento no no desde
ahora porque haya sequía sino desde el
primer momento a hacerlo es una
necesidad que se tiene en el país que ya
como ya te lo decía de la década del 70
es un es una sugerencia importante que
nos habían hecho a a nuestros gobiernos
y bueno eso es una realidad como te
decía también este Raúl recién el
gobierno ha implementado distintas
medidas que tienen que ver con el tema
de los impuestos al al agua envasada
para mesa como tiene también que ver con
el Ministerio de desarrollo social de
brindar a todas las a todos lados los
vecinos con más problemas de
vulnerabilidad brindarles este el agua
para el consumo
hay Hay muchísimas medidas que se han
tomado y que se están trabajando para
por el tema de la emergencia pero
también se está trabajando por el tema
de solucionar la infraestructura
y el acceso y asegurar el acceso al agua
potable de aquí en alemán
Le quiero preguntar a Raúl porque
también hay ayudas por parte de
Argentina y Brasil Usted cree que son
suficientes al menos para paliar lo más
crítico de la crisis actual
Bueno siempre todo ayuda es bienvenida
pero tenemos que entender claramente que
el volumen de ayuda de lo que puede
venir de otros países en este momento no
puede de ninguna manera solucionar la
crisis la crisis la tenemos que
solucionar entre nosotros en el momento
actual la solución es que llueva eso no
hay otra salvación porque al no haberse
desarrollado las infraestructuras
previamente y al no haberse trabajado
sobre este tema de manera adecuada
anteriormente hoy no tenemos otra
salvación que no sea abundante lluvia y
esperemos que se dé ha cambiado en algo
la situación atmosférica en el Pacífico
estamos cambiando de la situación de la
niña Niño ese proceso normalmente en
nuestro país significa un aumento en la
precipitaciones pero quiero expresar
algo y Es que desde el movimiento por un
lugar sustentable y de otros movimientos
de la academia la universidad de la
República algunos estudios de
universidades privadas estamos
absolutamente contrarios al
empecinamiento que tiene el gobierno con
llevar adelante el proyecto de arasatí
para obtener agua dado que ese proyecto
va a sacar agua del río de la plata en
una zona en la cual se dan periodos de
salinidad abundante que lo hacen
absolutamente no operativo ese proyecto
el año pasado Solamente en esa zona se
registró un solo episodio midió 86 días
de aguas al oro o sea tres meses en el
año que el proyecto no podría funcionar
O sea no podría sacar agua el proyecto
está mal dimensionado además es un
proyecto que no llega a cubrir el 40% de
las necesidades actuales de Montevideo
como yo decía hoy desgastar dinero en
ese proyecto Cuando tenemos las redes en
mal estado no es lo que uno hace en su
casa y por otra parte es una lástima que
tenga que decirlo así pero realmente a
nosotros nos indigna pensar que un
proyecto cuyo precio supuestamente son
250 millones de dólares se está pensando
en pagarse un consor empresas privadas
que lo presentaron como propio cuando
como dice Carol era un proyecto que
existía desde los años 70 lo presentaron
como propio para obtener ventajas
impositivas y lo van a cobrar
740 millones de dólares o sea tres veces
más es absolutamente inaceptable
malgastar los recursos públicos en un
proyecto que no cubre las necesidades en
un proyecto que toda la academia está en
contra el empecinamiento por sacar agua
del río de la plata específicamente en
ese punto de arasatí no tiene ninguna
pero ninguna ningún soporte lógico ni
ningún soporte científico no hay ningún
estudio que diga que el agua se puede
sacar de ahí y sea bien sacarla hay
multitud de estudios que dicen
Exactamente lo contrario el río de la
plata es fuente de agua pero no a esa
altura Colonia y Juan la calle dos
localidades costeras de nuestro país
Colonia patrimonio histórico de la
humanidad se sirve en el río de la plata
para el agua pero están a más de 180
kilómetros Aproximadamente a 180
kilómetros río arriba de Montevideo
Buenos Aires también lo hace hacer el
proyecto no se justifica pagarlo lo que
se piensa pagar no tiene sentido
nosotros en ese caso en ese sentido
estamos absolutamente Opuestos a esto y
nos hemos opuesto de todas las maneras
posibles proponiendo otras cosas
proponiendo que se estudie en otros
lugares en el río de la plata
proponiendo como yo decía recién Buscar
el agua que ya es dulce y segura en
otros Ríos cuidando mejor la Cuenca de
del río Santa Lucía y haciendo las obras
en el río Santa Lucía que estaban
previstas desde hace mucho tiempo no
solamente La Represa esta de
de de la zona norte sino también La
Represa también en el soldado O sea que
el soldado dos arroyos otros proyectos y
tiene razón Carol que ese proyecto de
sacar de la plata y específicamente en
arassati por alguna extraña razón que no
tiene justificación técnica ya existía
desde el año setenta pero en el en los
estudios del año 70 el proyecto fue
rechazado y se rechazó por dos razones
la salinidad de las aguas y el alto
costo de desarrollar las cañerías En
aquel momento a más de 80 kilómetros de
distancia claro
preguntar aquí Cómo cómo defender
entonces este proyecto pese a sus altos
tantos niveles de sal como el precio
en 50 años o más de 50 años ha
evolucionado muchísimo la tecnología
entonces lo que se rechazaba de pronto
por tema de salinidad o u otros temas
tecnológicos hace más de 50 años hoy
este es totalmente viable como yo te
decía en el 2016 estuve cuando estaba
trabajando como senadora en mi país
estuve invitada junto a otros
legisladores a conocer Israel y al
Líbano y y una de las cosas que yo pedí
conocer y entender más es cómodo el
manejo de agua que tenían en Israel y la
verdad que es impresionante la capacidad
de tecnológica y el manejo geopolítico
que hacen del agua y y bueno y allá
tienen plantas este de Salina para para
sacarle la salinidad al agua y darle
acceso a agua potable a toda su
población
esa tecnología y otras más que hay en el
mundo dan la viabilidad al proyecto
grasa a ti al proyecto de la sati es un
proyecto que le da la aseguranza al país
a la zona metropolitana que hoy no tiene
y Estoy totalmente a favor de que se
avance Cómo se ha avanzado para darle
seguridad a nuestros vecinos de que no
van a volver a tener esta a sufrir esta
emergencia
hídrica también obviamente hay que
avanzar en los embalses que ya también
estaban programados y que se sabía desde
hace mucho tiempo que se tenían que
hacer que lamentablemente a nosotros en
nuestro gobierno nos ya la sequía la
sequía ya venía este avanzando cuando en
el hace tres años este nuestro
presidente asumió en en el país No
no es esto no echarle la culpa a nadie
en verdad es un problema de todos y
también una responsabilidad de todos de
los políticos y los que no son políticos
porque cuando en el 2015 hablábamos de
de la importancia de cuidar la calidad
de cuidar nuestra agua y de tener una
visión un poco más este
de sentirnos integrados al ambiente y a
la naturaleza muchísimo de nuestros
vecinos este no lo entendían así hoy
como todo también las crisis nos traen
oportunidades y hoy tenemos una
oportunidad de empezar a dar las cosas
de otra manera de de poner en la hojita
de prioridades el agua y también
obviamente este el acceso al agua
potable claro usted señala que esto
venía desde antes hemos hablado desde
los embalses que no se han construido en
más de 40 a 50 años a pesar de su
necesidad y de una sequía que ya había
comenzado una vez el gobierno de Luis
lacalle Pou comenzó a ejercer el control
del país pero quiero hacerle una
pregunta Se demoró demasiado el
presidente en declarar el estado de
emergencia teniendo en cuenta que lo
declara el 19 de junio a pesar de que la
crisis hídrica Comenzó desde finales de
abril en mayo ya se preveía que la
capital se podía quedar sin agua y que
los niveles de paso Severino alcanzan el
3% esto de manera comparativa para
nuestra audiencia les recuerdo que en
Sudáfrica está el caso de Ciudad del
Cabo que se iba a declarar el famoso día
cero que es el día en el que la ciudad
se quedaría sin agua una vez los niveles
estuvieran por debajo del 13% y ahí
comenzarían las actividades de
emergencia y sin embargo ciudad del Cabo
logró evitar esta crisis hídrica vemos
comparativamente Que Montevideo los
niveles de agua son mucho más inferiores
a este nivel y que el estado de
emergencia Se demoró Se demoró o no
la verdad que yo no puedo este decirle
si se demoró lo que sí sé es que se han
tomado acciones muy importantes
Reconozco el trabajo que está haciendo
todo nuestra nuestra gente que está este
en ose por ejemplo sé de de su empeño de
su trabajo de la preocupación del
presidente por este tema y de las
acciones que se han tomado
Que bueno que se está innovando en
nuestro país No es que hace 70 años no
pasaba no hay registros hace 70 y pico
de años empezaron a hacer registros creo
Claro este no hay registros de una de
una sequía de esta magnitud y los
meteorólogos nos decían que llovía y yo
vivo en una zona donde tiene que llover
para que Montevideo tenga agua y y nos
decían que llovía y se hacían las
tormentas y se iban Y no llovía y así
venimos hace muchos meses lo que sí se
ha asegurado es que Montevideo no se sin
agua porque el problema Sería que una
ciudad cualquiera se quede sin agua
potable o no potable se quede sin agua
porque ahí sí vendría un problema
sanitario importante porque cuánto
duraría una familia cuánto podría estar
en su casa Sin poder tener agua para
lavarse las manos o para lavar el baño o
tirar la cadena para
limpiar este la voy a interrumpir porque
se nos acaba el tiempo y quiero darle la
oportunidad a Raúl para que muy
brevemente nos conteste se demoró el
presidente Luis la calle en decretar la
emergencia
yo estimo que sí que podría haberla
decretado antes porque la situación
venía mal pero quiero hacer una
aclaración el proyecto que se prevé
hacer en arasatí yo reconozco lo que
hace Israel otros países que necesitan
hacerlo porque no tienen Fuente de Agua
Uruguay tiene fuentes de agua dulce el
proyecto de arasatí no incluye la
desalinización no se va a sacarle la sal
al agua ese proyecto es una gran pérdida
de dinero es una gran pérdida para todos
es una gran oportunidad para algunas
empresas que van a ganar mucho dinero y
nosotros lo vemos como algo que como
país tendríamos que negarnos a hacer
repensarlo en todo caso puede ser el río
de la plata pero no allí Y
lamentablemente el proyecto no incluye
la desalinización es solamente sacar
agua potabilizarla y el agua salada no
se puede potabilizar entonces ya veremos
Entonces qué pasa tanto con este
proyecto como con Montevideo y esperamos
tal como lo dice Carol que no se quede
sin agua Carola viaga y Raúl viñas
Gracias por acompañarnos y también le
agradezco a Andrés doncel por la
producción de este programa y la de los
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera sigan con nosotros en France 24
[Música]